you're talking about collabo is he
friendly the scratch okay
beautiful I want to swim in you your new
album's called ocean yet spent the day
on a yacht with something who would it
be
fiance easy easy just for your friends
yeah I'm just putting it out there
famous for rent I could Darius Rucker
and alright he's like my best friend she
said he's always a good time he's they
never disobey our literal friends are we
supposed to I mean you never know any in
this industry that could be your best
principal I just she just always looks
so glamorous on a yacht I would yeah all
day we just hang out here would you
trust to babysit your kids
yeah should say Beyonce yeah yes yes
perfect every question thanks Carly it
would be an amazing thing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
who could you call at 2:00 a.m. there's
room Kelsea Ballerini tyler cupboard
that's you these are the real dependable
people yeah it's not get their number
who would you bring to the RO yeah
everybody out I mean guys it would be an
interesting one
[Music]
[Applause]
who is your biggest yeah yeah my boy for
sure is Beyonce
[Laughter]